I am banned by Fox News The Daily signal
quotes a former Tucker producer who says
that I have been blacklisted by the
network due to my Frank condemnation of
trans ideology and this is not I will
tell you news to me in fact um I
personally began hearing from sources
inside Fox dating back to last June that
the decision had been made to block me
from appearing on any fox show because
of my anti-trans ideology stance
especially after I criticized that fox
segment promoting the transiting of kids
I used to appear frequently on Laura
Ingram show and Jesse Waters in the past
I'd made numerous appearances on Fox and
Friends in the morning all of that went
away and this was not a surprise to me I
figured that would probably happen when
I called them out for promoting child
grooming I was also a regular
contributor on Tucker's show up till
that point and I heard from multiple
sources that when Tucker found out about
my black listing he was livid and he
fought back against it internally and
even managed to have me on his show a
few times over the next year in spite of
the directives from up top